good afternoon folks uh welcome to
lecture 18. today we'll be talking about
some of the latest and greatest
developments in neural nlp
where we've come and where we're headed
uh chris just to be sure
uh
are my present and what's visible from
this part is it fine
you're visible
okay uh but none of my presenters right
correct okay great thank you
um
so just as a reminder note that your
guest lecture reactions are due tomorrow
at 11 59 pm uh great job with the
project milestone reports you should
have received feedback now if not
contact the co-staff i think uh you know
we had some last minute issues uh but if
that's not resolved please contact us um
uh finally the project reports are due
very soon uh on the march 16th which is
next week there's one question on ed
about
the leaderboard and uh the last day to
summon on the leaderboard is march 19th
uh
as well
okay so for today we'll start by talking
about extremely large language models
and gpd3 that have recently gained a lot
of popularity
we'll then take a closer look at
compositionality and generalization of
these neural models
um while transformer models like bird
and gpt have really high performance on
all benchmarks they still fail in really
surprising ways when deployed how can we
strengthen our understanding of
evaluating these models so they more
closely reflect task performance
in the real world
and then we end by talking about how we
can move beyond this really limited
paradigm of teaching models language
only through text and look at language
grappling
finally i'll give some practical tips on
how to move forward in your neural nlp
research and this will include some
practical tips for the final project as
well
okay
so uh you know this this beam really
kind of captures uh
you know what's been going on in the
field really and it's it's just that our
ability to harness unlabeled data has
vastly increased over the last few years
and this has been made possible due to
advances in not just hardware but also
systems and our understanding of like
self-supervised uh training so we can
use like lots and lots of un-given data
um
so based on this here's a general
representation learning recipe that just
works for you know all basically most
modalities
so the the recipe is uh is basically as
follows so convert your data if it's
images converted
or like it's not uh
it's it's really modality agnostic so
you take your data if it's images text
or videos and you convert it into a
sequence of integers
and in step two we define a loss
function to maximize data likelihood or
create a denoising autoencoder loss
finally in step three train on lots and
lots of data
um
certain properties emerge only when we
scale up model size and this is really
the surprising fact about scale
so to give some examples of this recipe
in action here's gpd3 which can learn to
do a really non-trivial classification
problem with just two demonstrations
and we'll talk more about this soon
um
another example as we saw in lecture 14
is d5 which does really effective close
book qa by storing knowledge in
parameters
uh finally just so i covered another
modality here's a recent
text to image
generation model with really impressive
zero shot generalization
okay so now let's talk about gpd3
so how big really are these models uh
this table kind of presents some numbers
to put things in perspective
um so this so we have a collection of
models starting with medium-sized lstms
which was sort of a staple in pre-2016
nlp
all the way to humans who have 100
trillion synapses and some in the middle
we have gbt2 with over a billion
parameters and gpt3 with over 150
billion parameters
and this exceeds the number of synaptic
connections in a honeybee brain
so obviously anyone with little
knowledge of neuroscience and knows that
this is not an apples to oranges
comparisons uh that this is an apple
store in this comparison but the point
here is that the scale of these models
is really starting to reach astronomical
numbers
um
so here are some facts about gbt3 uh for
one it's a large transformer with 96
layers
um
it has more or less the same
architecture as gpd2
with the exception that to scale up
attention computation uh it uses these
locally banded sparse attention patterns
and i really encourage you to look at
the paper to understand the details the
reason we mentioned this here is because
it kind of highlights that scaling up is
simply not just changing hyper
parameters as many might believe and it
involves really non-trivial engineering
and algorithms to make computations
efficient
finally all of this is trained on 500
billion tokens taken from the common
crawl toronto books corpus wikipedia
[Music]
so what's new about gpp3 right so let's
let's look at some of the results on the
paper first so obviously it does better
on language modeling and text completion
problems
as you can see from this table it does
better than gpt2 at language modeling in
the pentree bank as well as better on
story completion on the story completion
data set called ambada
to give a flavor of what's to come uh
let's take a closer look at this
limbaugh story completion data set
so the task here is that we're given a
short story and we are supposed to fill
in the last word
um satisfying the constraints uh
of the problem can be hard for a
language model which could generate a
multi-word completion
with gpd3 the really new thing is that
we can just give a few examples as
prompts and sort of communicate a task
specification to the model and now gpt3
knows how the completion must be a
single word this is a very very powerful
paradigm and we give some more examples
of this in context learning in a couple
more slides
so apart from language modeling it's
really good at these knowledge intensive
tasks like uh close book qa as well as
reading comprehension and here we
observe that scaling our parameters
results in a massive improvement in
performance
so now let's talk about in context
learning uh gbt3 demonstrates some level
of fast adaptation to completely new
tasks
this happens via what's called in
context learning
as shown in the figure the model
training can be characterized as having
an outer loop
that learns a set of parameters that
makes the learning of the inner loop as
efficient as possible and with this sort
of framework in mind we can really see
how a good language model can also serve
as a good few short learner
so in this segment we will have some fun
with gpd3 and look at some
demonstrations of this in context
learning
um
[Music]
so uh to start up here is an example
where someone's trying to create an
application that converts language
a language description uh to bash one
language the first three examples are
prompts followed by generated examples
from gpd3
uh so it gets a list of running
processes right this one's easy probably
just involves looking at a hash table
some of the more challenging ones that
involve copying over
um you know some uh
spans from the text like the scp example
is kind of interesting as well as the
harder one to parse grip the scp example
comes up a lot uh during office hours so
gpd3 knows how to do that
here's a somewhat more challenging one
where the model is given a description
of a database in natural language
and it starts to emulate that behavior
so the text in bold is sort of the
prompt given to the model the prompt
includes somewhat of a functional
function specification of what a
database is
so it says that the database begins
knowing nothing
the database knows everything that's
added to it the database does not know
anything else
and when you ask a question to the
database if the answer is there in the
database the database must return the
answer otherwise it should say it does
not know the answer
so this is very new and very powerful um
and you know the prompt also includes
some example usages so when you ask two
plus two the database does not know you
ask the capital of france the database
does not know and then you add in a fact
that tom is 20 years old to the database
and now you can start asking it
questions like where does tom live
and as expected it says that the
database does not know
but now if you ask it what's tom's age
uh the database says that tom is 20
years old and if you ask what's my age
the database says
basically that it does not know because
that's not been added so this is really
powerful
um here's another one
uh now uh in this example the model is
asked to blend concepts together and so
there's a definition of what does it
mean to blend concepts so if you take
airplane and car you can blend that to
your flying car
that's essentially
you know there's a wikipedia definition
of what concept blending it
concept blending is along with some
examples
and now let's look at uh you know some
some some problems followed by what gp3
answers
so the first one is
straightforward two-dimensional space uh
blended with 3d space gives 2.5
dimensional space
the one that is somewhat interesting is
old and new gives recycled
um
then triangular square gives trapezoid
that's also interesting
the one that's like really non-trivial
is a geology plus neurology used to
sediment neurology and i had no idea
what this was it's apparently correct um
so clearly it it's able to do these very
flexible things just from a just from
prompt
so here's another you know class of
examples that gbt3
uh you know gets somewhat right and
these are uh these copycat analogy
problems which have been really well
studied in cognitive science science
and the way it works is that i'm going
to give you some examples and then ask
you to
uh you know introduce a function from
these examples and apply it to you apply
to like new queries so if abc changes to
abt what does pqr change to well pqr
must change to pqs because the function
we've learned is that the last letter
must be incremented by one
and and this function uh humans can now
apply to examples of like you know
varying types so like uh p repeated
twice q repeated twice r repeated twice
much change to be repeated twice q
repeated twice and s repeated twice um
and it seems like gpd3 is able to get
them right uh more or less
but uh the problem is that if you if you
ask it to generalize to uh you know
examples that have increasing number of
repetitions then were seen in the prompt
it's not able to do that so in this
situation uh you ask it to
you know
make an analogy where um
the the the letters are repeated four
times and it's never seen that before it
doesn't know what to do
and so it gets all of these wrong so you
know there's a point to be made here
about uh
just like maybe these prompts are not
enough to convey uh you know the
function the model should be learning
and maybe even more examples that you
can learn but the point is that
it probably doesn't um it probably it
probably does not have the same kind of
generalization that humans have
and that brings us to sort of the
limitations of these modules and some
some open questions so just looking at
the paper and uh you know passing
through the results
it seems like the model is bad at
logical
logical and mathematical reasoning
anything that involves doing multiple
steps uh of reasoning and that explains
why it's bad at arithmetic why it's bad
at work problems why it's not great at
analogy making and even like traditional
textual entailment data sets that seem
to require logical reasoning like rte
so second most subtle point is that it's
unclear how we can uh make permanent
updates to the model like maybe if i
want to teach a model a new concept
that's possible to do it
while i'm interacting with the system
but once the interaction is over
it kind of restarts and does not have a
notion of knowledge and it's not that
this is something that the model cannot
do in principle but just something
that's not really been explored
[Music]
um it doesn't seem to exhibit human-like
generalization which is often called
systematicity and i'll talk a lot more
about that
and finally language is situated and
gpt3 is just learning from text and
there's no exposure to other modalities
there's no interaction so maybe the
aspects of meaning that it requires are
like somewhat limited and maybe we
should explore how we can bring in other
modalities
so we'll talk a lot more about uh these
last uh a lot last few limitations the
rest of the lecture
but maybe i can possibly some questions
now if there are
[Music]
any i don't think there's a big
outstanding question but i mean i think
some people aren't really clear on you
know few shot setting and prompting
versus learning and i think it might
actually be good to explain that a bit
more
okay yeah so
um
so maybe let's
let me pick a simple example
um let me pick this example here
so uh prompting just means that so gpd3
like if you go back to first principles
right gbt3 is basically just a language
model and what that means is uh given a
context it'll tell you what's the
probability of of the next word right so
if i give it a context
uh w1 through wk uh gpd3 will tell me
what's the probability
of w uh k plus one for
you opens the vocabulary so that's
that's what a language model is
uh a prompt is essentially a context
that gets pre-bended before gt3 can
start uh generating
and what's happening with in context
learning is that the uh
the context that you append uh that that
you that you pre-pen to gp3
are basically xy examples
um
so that's that's the prompt and the
reason why it's also uh
it's equivalent to few short learning is
because you pre-bend a small number of
xy examples so in this case if i just
prepend this uh this one example that's
highlighted in purple then that's
essentially one shot learning because i
just give it a single example as context
and now like given uh you know given
this query which is also appended due to
the model it has to make a prediction
so
um
so the input output format is the same
as how a few shot learner uh would
receive but since it's a language model
the training data set is essentially
presented as a context
so someone is still asking can you be
more specific about the in-context
learning setups what is the task
right so um
so let's see maybe i can go to
um
yeah so maybe i can go to this slide
so the task is
just that i'm it's a language model so
it gets a context
which is just a sequence of tokens and
the task is just to you know uh
uh so you have a sequence of tokens and
then
the model has to generate given a
sequence of tokens
and the way you can convert that into an
actual machine learning classification
problem
is that uh
so for this example maybe you give it 5
plus 8 equals 13
7 plus 2 equals 9 and then one plus zero
equals and now gpd3 can fill in
uh you know a number there so that's how
you convert it into a classification
problem the context here would be these
two examples of
uh of arithmetic like five plus eight
equals thirteen and seven plus two
equals nine and then the query is one
plus zero equals and then the model
since it's just a language model has to
fill in one plus zero equals question
mark so it fills in something that
doesn't have to fill in numbers it could
fill in anything and but if it fills in
a one uh you know it does the right job
so that's how you can take like a
language model and do few shot learning
with it
i'll keep on these questions how is in
context learning different from transfer
learning
so i i guess the
like
in in context learning i mean you can
think of in context learning as being a
kind of transfer learning but like
transfer learning does not specify the
mechanism through which the transfer is
going to happen within context learning
the mechanism is that
the training examples are sort of
appended to the model
which is a language model just uh you
know
in order so let's say you have
x y x one y one x two y two and these
are just appended directly to the model
and now it makes prediction on you know
some query uh
some some queries that are drawn from
this data set so yes it is uh it is a
sub-category of transfer learning but
transfer learning does not specify
um exactly how this transfer learning is
achieved but in context learning is very
specific and says that for language
models you can essentially concatenate
the training data set and then present
that to the language model
people still aren't sufficiently clear
on what is or isn't happening with
learning
and prompting
so you know another question is so in
context learning still needs fine tuning
question mark we need to train gpt 3 to
do in context learning
question mark
right so
um
so there are two parts to this question
right so
uh so the answer is yes and no so of
course the the model is a language model
so it needs to be trained so you start
with some random parameters and you need
to train them but the model is trained
as a language model
right and once the model is trained
you can now use it uh to do transfer
learning
and the model parameters in in context
learning are fixed you do not update the
model parameters
all you do is that you give it these uh
you know small training set to the model
which is just appended to the model as
context
and now the model can start generating
from that point on
so in this example
if 5 minus 8 equals 13 and 7 plus 2
equals 9 are two xy examples
in in
vanilla transfer learning what you would
do is that you would take some great in
steps update your model parameters and
then make a prediction on one plus zero
equals what right but within context
learning all you're doing is you just
concatenate uh
5 plus 8 equals 13 and 7 plus 2 equals 9
to the model's context window and then
make it uh predict what one plus 0
should be equal to
maybe we should end for now with one
other bigger picture question which is
do you know of any research combining
these models with reinforcement learning
for the more complicated reasoning tasks
so that is an excellent question uh
there is some recent work on kind of
trying to align
um language models with human
preferences where
yes there is like uh you know some
amount of fine tuning
with reinforcement learning based on
like these preferences from humans so
maybe you want to do a summer you want
to do a summarization problem with gbd3
and the model produces multiple
summaries and for each summary maybe you
have a reward that is essentially a
human preference like maybe i want to
include some facts and i don't want to
include you know some other uh
non-important facts and so i can
construct a reward out of that and i can
fine-tune the parameters of my language
model uh basically using uh
reinforcement learning based on this
reward which is essentially human
preferences uh so there's some very
recent work that tries to do this but
i'm not sure uh yeah i'm not aware of
any work that tries to use reinforcement
learning to teach her reasoning i did
these models but i think it's a
interesting future direction to explore
maybe you should go on at this point
okay
okay so we'll talk a bit more about
these last two points uh so
systematicity
and
language grounding
um
so just to start off like how do you
define systematicity so really the
definition is
that there is a definite and predictable
pattern among the sentences that native
speakers of a language understand
and so there's a systematic pattern
among the sentences that we understand
what that means is let's say there's a
sentence like john loves me
right and if a native speaker
understands the sentence then they
should also be able to understand the
sentence mary loves john
and closely related to this idea of
systematicity is the principle of
compositionality and for now i'm going
to
uh you know ignore the definition by
montague and just look at the rough
definition and then we can come back to
this other like more concrete definition
the rough definition is essentially that
the meaning of an expression
is a function of the meaning of its
parts
so that brings us to the question are
human languages really compositional and
here are some examples that
you know make us think that maybe
uh yes so like if you look at what is
the meaning of the noun phrase brown cow
so it is composed of the meaning of the
adjective brown and and the noun cow um
so all things that are brown and all
things are a cow take the intersection
and get brown cows similarly red rabbits
so all things that are red all the
things are rather combining them get red
and then kick the ball this work phrase
can be understood as you have some agent
that's you know performing a
like kicking operation on the ball
uh but this this is not always the case
that uh you can like get the meaning
of the whole by combining meanings of
parts so here we have some counter
examples that people often use so like a
red herring does not mean all things
that are red and all things that are
heading and kick the bucket
definitely does not mean that there's an
agent that's kicking the bucket so uh
while these examples like are
supposed to be provocative like we think
that language is like mostly
compositional there's lots of exceptions
but
for vast majority of sentences that
we've never heard before we're able to
understand what they mean by piecing
together the words that the sentence is
composed of
and so what that means is that maybe
compositionality of representations are
helpful prior that could lead to
systematicity in behavior
um
and that brings us to the questions that
we ask in the segment are neural
representations compositional and the
second question is
if so do they generalize systematically
um
so
how do you even
measure if representations that on your
network learns
exhibit compositionality
um so let's uh let's go back to this
definition from logic u
which says that compositionality is
about the existence of a homomorphism
from syntax to something
um and to look at that we have this
example which is lisa does not
skateboard and we have a syntax tree uh
corresponding to this example
and the meaning of the sentence can be
composed
in uh according to
according to the structure that's
decided by the syntax so meaning of lisa
does not skateboard it's a function of
the meaning of lisa and does not
skateboard the meaning of does not skate
but is a function of does and not
skateboard meaning of not skateboard is
a function of north and skateboard
so that's good um and so this gives us
one way of formalizing how we can
measure compositionality in neural
representations and so compositionality
of representations
could be thought of as how well the
representation approximates an
explicitly homomorphic homomorphic
function and learned in a large
representation space so what we are
going to do is essentially measure if we
were to construct a neural network that
whose computations are based exactly
according to these parse trees
how far are the representations of our
learnt model
from this explicitly compositional uh
representation
and that gave us some understanding of
how compositional the neural networks
representations really are
uh so to unpack that a little bit uh
instead of having um
yeah so so instead of having uh
denotations we have uh representations
uh uh in the node uh
and
to like kind of be more concrete about
that
uh we first start by choosing a distance
function that tells us how far away two
representations are and then we also
need a way to compose together two
constituents to give us uh sort of the
meaning of of the whole
and but once we have that we can start
by uh we can create like an explicitly
compositional function right so what we
do is uh we have these
uh we have these uh representations at
the leaves that are initialized randomly
and the composition function that's also
initialized randomly and then a forward
pass according to this syntax is used to
compute the representation
of lisa does not skateboard and now once
you have this representation you can
create a loss function and this loss
function measures how far are the
representations of my neural network
from this second sort of proxy neural
network that i've created
and then i can uh
basically optimize both the composition
function
and the embeddings of the leaves
and then once the optimization is
finished i can measure how far
was the representation from of my neural
net from this explicitly compositional
network
on a held outside and that then tells me
whether the representation of my neural
net learnt were actually compositional
or not
so uh to see how well this works let's
look at a plot
and um this is relatively uh complex but
uh just to unpack this a little bit uh
it it
it plots uh the mutual information
between
uh the input that uh the neural network
receives
versus the representation
against this tree reconstruction error
that that we were talking about
and to give some more background about
what's to come
uh there is a theory of
the which is called the information
bottleneck theory which says that uh
as a neural network trains
uh it first
tries to maximize the mutual information
between the representation and the input
in an attempt to memorize the entire
data set
and that is called uh
that is our memorization phase and then
once memorization is done there is a
learning or a compression phase
where this mutual information starts to
decrease and the model is essentially
trying to compress the data
or consolidate the knowledge in the data
into its parameters
and what we are seeing here is that as a
model learns which is characterized by
decreasing major information
we see that the representations
themselves are becoming more and more
compositional
and overall we observe that learning is
correlated with increased
compositionality as measured by this
tree reconstruction error
so that's really encouraging
so uh now that we have a method of
measuring compositionality
uh of representations in these neural
nets
uh how do we you know start to create
benchmarks
now you know that let's see if they are
generalizing systematically or not
so to do that uh here's a method for
taking any data set and splitting it
into a trained test split uh that
explicitly tests for
this kind of generalization
so to do that we
use this principle called maximizing the
compound divergence
and to illustrate how this principle
works uh we
look at this toy example so in this toy
example we have a training data set
that consists of just two examples and
test data set of just two examples
um
the atoms that are defined as the
primitive elements uh so entity words
predicates question types so you know in
this toy example
goldfinger christopher nolan these are
all so the primitive elements and the
compounds are compositions of these
primitive elements so who directed
entity would be the composition of the
question type did x predicate y and and
the predicate direct
so here's a basic machinery for
producing compositionally challenging
splits
so uh let's start by introducing two
distributions the first distribution is
the normalized frequency distribution of
the atoms so given any data set if we
know what the notion of atoms are we can
basically compute the frequency of all
of the atoms and then normalize that by
the total count and that's going to give
us um one one distribution and we can
repeat the same thing for the compounds
and that'll give us a second uh
frequency distribution
so uh note that these are just two
probability distributions
and once we have these two distributions
we can essentially define
the atom and compound divergence
simply as uh this quantity here
and
where
there is the journal coefficient between
two categorical distributions the churn
of coefficient basis basically measures
uh how far two categorical distributions
are so just to get a bit more intuition
about this
uh if we set p to q
then the turn off coefficient is one
which means these
these representations are like maximally
similar and then if p is non-zero
everywhere q is zero um or or if or if p
is zero in all the places where q is
zero then the channel coefficient is
exactly uh is exactly zero which means
that these two distributions are
maximally far away
and uh the overall goal
by uh describing uh
this objective is that
uh this loss objective is just that we
are going to maximize the compound
divergence and minimize the atom
divergence and so what is the intuition
behind doing such a thing so what we
want is to ensure that the unigram
distribution
in some sense is constant between the
train and test split so that it's
uh so that the model does not encounter
any new words but we want the compound
divergence to be
very high which means that these same
words that the model has seen many times
must appear in new combinations which
means that we are testing for
systematicity
and so if you do uh if you follow this
procedure
for a semantic passing data set let's
say
what we see uh is that as you increase
the scale we see that the smaller just
does better and better
at a compositional generalization
but uh just pulling out a quote from
this this paper
pre-training helps for compositional
generalization but doesn't fully solve
it and what that means is that maybe as
you keep scaling up these models you'll
see better and better performance
or maybe it starts to saturate at some
point
in any case we should probably be
thinking more about this problem instead
of just trying to brute force it
so now uh this segment kind of tells us
that the way we split a data set you
know we can measure for like different
kinds of um
we can measure like different behaviors
of the model and that tells us that
maybe we should be like thinking more
critically about how we're evaluating
models in nlp in general
so
you know there has been a revolution
basically over the last few years in the
field where we're seeing all of these
large transform models be all of our
benchmarks at the same time there's uh
you know still
not complete confidence that once we
deploy these systems in the real world
they're going to you know be like
they're going to maintain their
performance
and so it's unclear if these gains are
coming from spurious correlations or
some real task understanding
and so how do we design benchmarks that
accurately tell us how well this model
is going to do in the real world
and so i'm going to give one example of
works that try to do this
and that's the idea of dynamic
benchmarks
and
what dynamic what the the idea of
dynamic benchmarks is basically saying
that instead of testing our models on
static uh on static test sets we should
be evaluating them on an ever-changing
dynamic benchmark
and there's many recent examples of this
and and the idea dates back to a 2017
workshop
at emlp
and so the overall schematic looks
something like this
that we start with a training data set
and a test data set which is the static
uh static order
we train a model on that and then once
the model is trained
uh we deploy that and then have humans
create new examples that the model fails
to classify
and
uh crucially we're looking for examples
the model does not get tried but humans
have no issue figuring out the answer to
so by playing this game of whack-a-mole
where
you know we
humans figure out what are sort of the
holes in the model's understanding
and then add that back into the training
data
retrain the model deploy it again have
humans create new examples we can
essentially construct this never-ending
uh you know data set this never-ending
test set
um which can hopefully
be a better proxy
of estimating real-world performance
um
so
so this is some really cutting-edge
research and one of the main challenges
of you know this
class of works is that it's unclear how
much this can scale up because
uh maybe after certain
after multiple iterations of this
whack-a-mole uh humans are just
fundamentally limited by creativity so
figuring figuring out how to uh you know
deal with that
is is really an open problem and kind of
approaches just use examples from other
datasets to you know prompt humans to
think more creatively
but maybe we can come up with like
better like more automated
methods of doing this
so uh this brings us to sort of the
final segment
or actually let me stop for questions at
this point and see if
people have questions
here's a question with dynamic benchmark
doesn't this mean that the model creator
will also need to continually
test slash evaluate the models on the
new benchmarks new data test new data
states
uh wait a second
sorry um
yeah so with with dynamic benchmarks yes
it's absolutely true that uh you will
have to continuously keep training your
model and that's just to ensure that
um
you know the the reason your model is
not doing well on the test set
doesn't have to do with like this domain
mismatch
um and what we're really trying to do is
like
you know
measure how like just come up with a
better estimate of the model's
performance for the overall task
and
just trying to get like more and more
data so yes to answer to answer your
question yes we need to keep like
training the model again and again but
this can be automated
okay so uh i'll move on to sort of
uh language grounding
so uh in this final step segment i'll
talk about how we can move beyond just
training models
uh on text alone
um
so
many have articulated
the need to use modalities other than
their ex if we someday want to get at
real language understanding
and uh this has you know ever since
we've had like these big language models
you know this there has been sort of a
rekindling of this debate and recently
there was uh multiple papers on this and
so at acl last year there was this paper
that argues uh through multiple thought
experiments that it's actually
impossible to acquire
meaning from form alone where meaning
refers to the communicative intent of a
speaker and form refers to
text or speech signals
um
a more modded version of this was put
forward by the second paper where they
say that training on only web scale data
kind of limits the world scope of models
and kind of limits uh the aspects of
meanings that the model can actually
acquire
um
and so here's sort of a diagram that
i've borrowed from the paper and what
they say is uh the era where we were
training modernism like supervised data
sets uh models were limited in words
called one and now that we've moved on
to exploiting like unlabeled data we're
now in world scope 2 where models just
have strictly more
signal to get more aspects of the
minimum
if you mix an additional modalities into
this so maybe you make some videos and
maybe you make some images
then that
expands out the world scope of the model
further and now maybe it can acquire
more aspects of meaning such that
now it knows that the
lexical item in red refers to you know
red images maybe
and then if you go beyond that you can
have a model
that is embodied and it's actually
living in an environment where it can
interact
uh with its data conduct um
interventions and experiments
and then if you go out uh go even beyond
that you can have models that live in a
social world where they can interact
with other models because after all the
purpose of language is to communicate
and so she can have like a social world
where
models can communicate with other models
that kind of expands out uh aspects of
meaning
[Music]
and so gpd3 is in world scope queue
so there are a lot of open questions in
this space
so given that there are all of these
good arguments about how we need to move
beyond text what is the best way to do
this at scale
um
we know that you know babies cannot
learn language from watching tv alone
for example so there has to be some
interventions and there has to be
interactions
that need to happen
but at the same time the question is how
far can models go
by just training on
static data
as long as we have additional modalities
especially when we combine this with
scale
and if interactions with the environment
are really necessary how do we collect
data and design systems that interact
minimally or in a cost effective way
and then finally put pre-training on
text still be useful if any of these
other
uh if any of these other like um any of
these other research directions uh
become more sample efficient
so if you're interested in learning more
about
this topic i highly encourage you to
take cs224u which is offered in spring
they have like multiple lectures on just
language
okay so in this final segment i'm gonna
talk a little bit more about how you can
get involved
with uh you know nlp and deep learning
research and how uh you know how you can
make more progress
so uh here are some general principles
for how to make progress in english and
research so i think the most important
thing is to just kind of read broadly
which means not just read the latest and
greatest papers in archive but also read
like pre-2010 statistical nlp
um
learn about the mathematical foundations
of machine learning to understand how
generalization works so take cs 29 m
uh learn more about language which means
taking uh classes in the linguistics
department in particular i would
recommend universe 138 and also take
cs224u
and finally if you wanted uh if you want
to take inspiration from how babies
learn then definitely read about child
language acquisition literature it's
fascinating
uh finally learn how to
learn your software tools which
involves scripting tools
uh version control
data wrangling uh learning how to
visualize quickly with jupiter notebooks
and deep learning often involves um you
know running multiple experiments with
different hyper parameters and different
ideas all in parallel and sometimes it
can get really hard to keep track of
everything so learn how to use
experiment management tools like weights
and biases
and uh finally i'll talk about some
really quick final project tips
um
so firstly let's just start by saying
that if your approach doesn't seem to be
working please do not panic
uh put assert statements everywhere and
check if the computations that you're
doing are correct
use breakpoints extensively and i'll
talk a bit more about this
uh check if the loss function that
you've implemented is correct
and one way of debugging that is to see
that uh the initial values are correct
so if you're doing a kva classification
problem then the initial loss should be
the natural log of k
always always always start by creating a
small training data set which has like
five to ten examples and see if your
model can completely overfit that if not
there's a problem with your training
loop
um
check for saturating activations and
dead values and often this can be fixed
by
you know like maybe there's some
problems to gradient so maybe there's
some problem with the initialization
which brings me to the next point check
your gradient values see if they're too
small which means that maybe you should
be using residual connections or lstms
or if they're too large then you should
use gradient clipping in fact always use
gradient clipping um
overall be methodical if your approach
doesn't work come up with hypotheses or
for why this might be the case design
oracle experiments to debug it look at
your data and look at the errors that
it's making and just try to be
systematic about everything
so um i'll just say a little bit more
about uh breakpoints uh so there's this
great library called pdb it's like gdp
but it's for python so that's why pdb
um to create to create a breakpoint just
add the line import pdb pdb set trace
before the line you want to inspect so
earlier today i was trying to play
around with uh with the transformers
library
so uh and i was trying to do question
answering so i have a really small
training corpus and the context is one
morning i shot an elephant in my pajamas
how he got into my pajamas i don't know
and the question is what did i shoot
and to do to solve this problem i
basically imported a tokenizer
and a birth model
um and i you know initialize my
tokenizer initialize my model like
tokenize my input i set my model into
the eval mode and i try to look at the
artwork
but i get this error
and i'm very sad it's not clear what's
causing this error
and so the best way to look at what's
causing this error is to actually put a
breakpoint
um so right after modular eval i put a
breakpoint because i know that that's
where the problem is so the problem is
in 21 so i put a breakpoint at line 21
and now once i put this breakpoint i can
just
run my script again and it stops before
executing line 21 and at this point i
can examine all of my variables so i can
look at the token as input because maybe
that's where the problem is and lo and
behold i see that it's actually
a list so it's a dictionary of lists
whereas modules typically expect a dodge
tensor so now i know what the problem is
and that means i can quickly go ahead
and fix it
and everything just works uh so this
just shows that you should use
breakpoints everywhere uh if your code
is not working and it can just like help
you debug really quickly um
okay so uh finally i'll say that if you
want to get involved with nlp and deep
learning research and if you really like
the final project uh we have the clips
program at stanford and this is a way
for undergrads master students and phds
who are interested in doing nlp research
and want to get involved with the nlp
group um so we highly encourage you to
apply to clips
um
and so yeah so i'll uh conclude uh
continue today's class spicing that you
know we've made a lot of progress uh in
the last decade and that's mostly
due to you know clever understanding of
neural networks data hardware all of
that combined with scale we have some
really amazing technologies that can do
really exciting things and we saw some
examples of that today
um
in the short term uh i expect that we'll
see more scaling uh because it just
seems to help so perhaps even larger
models
uh but this is not trivial so you know i
i said that before and i'll just say it
again scaling requires really
non-trivial engineering efforts and
sometimes even you know clever
algorithms and so we there's a lot of
interesting systems work to be done here
but in the long term
uh we really need to be thinking more
about these bigger problems of like
systematicity generalization how can we
make our models you know learn a new
concept really quickly so that's fast
adaptation
uh and then we also need to you know
create benchmarks that we can actually
trust so if my model has some
performance on some sentiment analysis
data set and deployed in the real world
that should be reflected in the number
that i get from the benchmark so we need
to make progress
uh in in the way we evaluate models
and then also
figuring out a way to move beyond text
in a more tractable way this is also
really essential
so yeah that's that's it good luck with
your final projects
i can take more questions at this point
so
i answered a question earlier that
actually i think you
uh
could also find on um it was the
question of whether you have a large
model that's pre-trained on language if
it will actually help you in other
domains like you apply it to vision
stuff
uh
yeah
yeah so i guess uh the answer is
actually yes like there was a paper that
came out really really recently like
just two days ago that just takes uh
i think it was gpt too
i'm not sure it's like one large
transformer model that's featuring on
text
and like other dialogues
definitely apply to images and i think
they apply to like
uh
math problems and some more modalities
and show that it's actually really
effective at like transfer so if you pre
train on text and then you move to a
different modality that helps i think
part of the reason for that is just that
you know across modalities there is a
lot of auto aggressive structure that is
shared
um
and i i think one reason for that is
that
uh language is really referring to the
world around it and so you might expect
that
uh there is you know some
there is like some correspondence that's
just beyond the autoregressive structure
so there's also works that show that uh
if you have just
text only representations and image only
representations you can actually learn a
simple linear classifier that can learn
to align both of these representations
and all of these works are just showing
that there's actually a lot more common
between mortalities than we thought in
the beginning
uh so yeah i think
yeah it's it's possible to create a text
and then
fine-tune on your modality of interest
and
it should probably be effective
of course based on what the modality is
but yeah for like images and videos
it's certainly certainly effective
more questions
well a couple of questions have turned
up
one is what's the difference between cs
224 you and this class in terms of the
topics covered and focus
do you want to answer that one shakar or
should i have a go at answering it
maybe you should answer this one okay so
next quarter um cs224u
natural language understanding is
co-taught um by chris potts um and bill
mccartney um
so
you know
in essence um it's meant to be different
that natural language understanding
focuses on what its name is um sort of
how to build computer systems that
understand the sentences of natural
language
now you know in truth the boundary is
kind of complex because um we do some
natural language understanding in this
class as well and certainly for the
people who are doing the default final
project um question answering well
that's absolutely a natural language
understanding task
but the distinction is meant to be
that you know at least a lot of what we
do in this class
things like you know the assignment 3
dependency parser
or building the machine translation
system in
assignment 4 that they're in some sense
natural language processing
tasks where you know processing can mean
anything but commonly means you're doing
useful
useful intelligent stuff with um human
language input but you're not
necessarily deeply understanding it so
there is some
overlap in the classes um if you do
cs224u you'll certainly see word vectors
and transformers again but the emphasis
is on doing a lot more with natural
language understanding tasks and so that
includes
things like building semantic parsers so
they're the kind of devices that um will
you know respond to questions and
commands such as an alexa or google
assistant will do
building relation extraction systems
which get out particular facts out of a
piece of text of all this person took on
this position at this company
looking at grounded language learning
and grounded language understanding
where you're not only using
the language but the world context to
get information
and other tasks that sort i mean i guess
you can look at the website to get
more details of it i mean
you know relevant to this class i mean a
lot of people also find it an
opportunity to just get further in doing
a
project
in the area of natural language
processing that sort of by the nature of
the structure of the class since you
know it more assumes that people know
how to build deep learning natural
language
systems at the beginning that rather
than
a large percentage of the class going
into okay you have to do all of these
assignments although there are little
assignments earlier on that there's sort
of more time to work on a project for
the quarter
okay here's one more question that maybe
chicago could do
do you know of attempts to crowd source
dynamic benchmarks eg
uses uploading adversarial examples for
evaluation or online learning
yeah so actually like
uh the main
idea there is to use crowdsourcing right
so in fact there is this bench uh so
there is this um platform that was
created by bear it's called dyno bench
and the objective is just that that
to construct this slight dynamically
evolving
uh benchmark we are just going to
offload it to you know users of this
platform
and you can you know it essentially
gives you utilities for like uh
deploying your model and then having uh
you know humans kind of try to fool the
model
um
yeah so so this is like it's it's
basically
how the dynamic evaluate the dynamic
benchmark uh
collection actually works so like you uh
deploy a model
um
on some platform and then you get humans
to like fool the system
yeah
is a question can you address the
problems of nlp models not able to
remember really long contexts and
techniques to infer on really large
input length
yeah so
so i guess like there have been like a
few works recently right
that kind of tried to scale up
transformers to like really large uh
context lens uh one of them is like the
reformer
um and there's also like the transformer
excel that was i think the first one to
try and do that
um
i think what is unclear is whether
you can combine that with the scale of
these gpt-like
models and if you see like qualitatively
different things once you do that
like um and part of it is just that all
of this is just like so recent right uh
but yeah i think the open question there
is that
you know can you take these like really
long context transformers
that can operate over long context
combine that with scale of gpd3
and then get models that can actually
reason over these like really large
contexts
um
because i guess the hypothesis of scale
is that once you train language models
on uh at scale it can start to do these
things
and so to do that for long context we
actually need to like
have long context transformers that are
trained at scale and i i don't think
people have done that yet
so i'm seeing this other question about
language acquisition
[Music]
because do you have some thoughts on
this or
maybe i can just do something with that
um
yeah so the question is um what do you
think we can learn from baby language
acquisition can we build a language
model in a more interactive way like
reinforcement learning do you know
any of these attempts
oh that's that's a big huge question and
you know i think the the short
non-helpful answer is that there are
kind of no answers at the moment you
know people have certainly tried to do
things at various scales but you know we
just have
no technology that is the least bit
convincing um for being able to
replicate the language learning ability
of a human child um but after that
prologue what i could say is i mean yeah
there are definitely ideas to have in
your head so you know there are sort of
clear results which is that
little kids don't learn by watching
videos so it seems like interaction
is completely key
um little kids don't learn from language
alone they're in a very
rich environment where people are sort
of both learning stuff from the
environment in general and in particular
you know they're learning a lot from
what language acquisition risk um
researchers refer to as attention which
is different what we mean by attention
but it means that the caregiver will be
looking at the object that's the focus
of interest and you know commonly other
things as well like sort of you know
picking it up and bringing it near the
kid and all those kinds of things um
and you know
babies and young kids get to experiment
a lot right so regardless
of whether it's learning what happens
when you have um some blocks that you
stack up and play with them or you're
learning language you sort of experiment
by trying some things and
see what kind of response you get and
again that's essentially
building
on the interactivity of it that you're
getting some kind of response to any
upfronts you make and you know this is
something that's sort of been hotly
debated in the language acquisition
literature so a traditional chomp skin
position
is that you know
human beings don't get effective
feedback you know supervised labels when
they talk and you know in some very
narrow sense well that's true right it's
just not the case that after a baby
tries to say something that they get
feedback of you know syntax error in
english on word four
or they get
given here's the semantic form i took
away from your utterance
but
in a more indirect way they clearly get
enormous feedback they can see what kind
of response um they get from their
caregiver at every um corner and so like
in your question
um you were suggesting that well somehow
we should be
making use of reinforcement learning
because we have something like a reward
signal there um and you know in a big
picture way i'd say hi yeah i agree um
in terms of a much more specific way as
to well how can we possibly get that to
work to learn something with the
richness of human language i
you know
i think we don't have much idea but you
know there has started to be some work
so people have
been sort of building um virtual
environments which you know
you have your um
avatar in and that can manipulate in the
virtual environment and there's
linguistic input and it can succeed in
getting rewards for sort of doing a
command where the command can be
something like you know pick up the
orange block or something like that
and
you know
to a small extent people have been able
to build things that work i mean
as i as you might be picking up i mean i
guess
so far at least i've just been kind of
underwhelmed because it seems like the
complexity of what people have achieved
um is sort of
you know just so primitive compared to
the full complex complexity of language
right you know the kind of languages
that people have been able to get
systems to learn are ones that can yeah
do pick up commands where they can learn
you know blue cube versus um orange
sphere and that's sort of about how far
people have gotten and that sort of such
a teeny small corner of what's involved
in learning a human language
one thing i'll just add to that is
i i think there are some principles of
uh how kids learn that people have tried
to apply to deep learning and one
example that comes to mind is curriculum
learning
um
where there's like a lot of literature
that shows that you know babies uh they
tend to pay attention to things that
they just
that is just slightly challenging for
them and they don't pay attention to
things that are extremely challenging
and also don't pay attention to things
that they know how to solve
and many researchers have really tried
to get curriculum learning to work
um
and the verdict on that is that it seems
to kind of work when you're in like
reinforcement learning settings but it's
unclear if it's going to work on like
supervised learning settings but i still
think that it's like underexplored and
maybe
you know there should there should be
like more attempts to kind of see if we
can like
add in curriculum learning and if that
improves anything
yeah
i agree curriculum learning is an
important idea which we haven't really
talked about but it seems like it's
certainly essential to human learning um
and there's been some minor successes
with it in the machine learning world
but it sort of seems like it's an idea
you should be able to do a lot more with
in the future as you move from um
models that are just doing one narrow
task that's trying to do a more general
language acquisition
process
should i attempt this next question as
well okay the next question is is the
reason humans learn languages better
just because we are pre-trained over
millions of years of physics simulation
maybe we should um pre-train a model the
same way so i mean i presume what you're
saying is physics simulation um you're
evoking evolution when you're talking
about millions of years so you know this
is
a
controversial debated big question
um so
you know again
if i invoke chomsky again so noam
chomsky is sort of the
most famous um linguist in the world um
and you know essentially noam chomsky's
career starting in the 1950s is built
around the idea that
little children
get
such
um dubious linguistic input because you
know they hear a random bunch of stuff
they don't get much feedback on what
they say etc that language could not be
learned
empirically just from the data observed
and the only
possible assumption to work from is
significant parts of human language um
uh
innate or in the sort of human genome
babies are born with that and that
explains the miracle by which very
little humans um
learn amazingly fast how human languages
work
um
now to speak in credit for that idea for
those of you who have not been around um
little children i mean i i think one
does just have to acknowledge you know
human language acquisition by
live little kids i mean it does just
seem to be miraculous right but you go
through this sort of slow phase for a
couple of years where you know the
the kids sort of goose and gars some
syllables and then there's a fairly long
period where they picked up a few words
and they can say juice juice um when
they want to drink some juice and
nothing else and then it just sort of
seems like there's this phase change
where the kids suddenly realize wait
this is a productive generative sentence
system i can say whole sentences and
then in an incredibly
short period they sort of seem to
transition from saying one and two word
utterances to suddenly they can say you
know
daddy come home in garage
um pudding bike in garage and you go wow
how do they suddenly discover language
um so you know
so it is kind of amazing but um
personally for me at least
you know
i've just never believed the strong
versions of the hypothesis that human
beings have
much in the way of language specific
knowledge or structure in their brains
that comes from genetic inheritance like
clearly
humans do have these very clever brains
and if we're at the level of saying
being able to think or being able to
interpret the visual world
that's things that have developed over
tens of millions of years
and um evolution
can be a large part of the explanation
and
humans are
clearly born with lots of vision
specific hardware in their brains as are
a lot of other creatures
but when you come to language you know
no one
no one knows when language was in a sort
of a modern like form
first became available because you know
there aren't any fossils of people
saying
you know the word um spear or something
like that but you know to the extent
that there are estimates based on sort
so what you can see of the sort of
spread of
um
proto-humans and
their sort of apparent social structures
from so what you can find in fossils you
know most people guess that language is
at most a million years old and you know
that's just too short a time for any
significant eve for evolution to sort of
build any significant structure inside
human brains that's specific to language
so
i kind of think that the
working assumption has to be that sort
of there's just about nothing
specific to language and human brains
and you know the most plausible
hypothesis not that i know very much
about neuroscience when it comes down to
it is that humans were being able to
repurpose hardware that was originally
built for other purposes like visual
scene interpretation and memory and
that that gave a basis of sort of having
all this clever hardware that you could
then use for language so you know it's
kind of like gpus were invented for
playing computer games and we were able
to repurpose that hardware to do deep
learning
we've got
a lot of have uh come out at the end
okay so this one is answered live um
let's see
yeah if you could name i guess this is
for either of you one main bottleneck as
to um
uh if we could provide feedback
efficiently to our systems like babies
are given feedback what's the bottleneck
that remains in uh
trying to have more human-like language
acquisition
um i mean i sort of
i cannot find on this again or would you
start releasing something
yeah i was just gonna say that i think
it's a bit of everything
right like
i i think in terms of models
um one thing i'll say is that we know
that there's more feedback connections
and feedback connections in the brain
um and we haven't really figured out a
way of
kind of
uh so you know of course we had rnns um
you know which sort of implement like
you know you can like look through an
item that sort of implements a feedback
loop but
we still haven't really figured out how
to you know
use that knowledge that the brain has a
lot of feedback connections and then
apply that to
uh like practical practical systems i
think on the modeling and like maybe
that's one problem
um
there is like yeah i think curriculum
learning is maybe one of them
but i think the one that's probably
gonna have most bang for buck is really
figuring out how we can move beyond text
i think there's just like so much of
more information that's available that
we're just not using
and so i think that's where most of the
progress might come from like figuring
out what's the most practical
of going beyond text
uh
this is what i think
okay um
let's see
uh what are some important nlp topics
that we have not covered in this class
i do that um
you know well sort of one answer is a
lot of the topics that are covered in
cs224u
because you know we do make a bit of an
effort to keep them disjoint they're not
fully um
right so there's sort of lots of topics
in language understanding that we
haven't
covered right so if you want to
make um
a voice assistant like alexa siri or
google assistant well you need to sort
of be able to interface with systems
apis that can do things like delete your
mail or buy you concert tickets and so
you need to be able to convert from
language into a explicit semantic form
that can interact with the systems of
the world we haven't talked about that
at all um so there's lots of language
understanding stuff there's also
lots of
language generation
things so you know effectively for
language generation all we have done
is neural language models they are great
um run them and they will generate
language and you know in one sense
that's true right like it's just awesome
the kind of generation you can do
with
things like gpt two or three
but you know
where that's
missing
is that's really only giving you the
ability to produce
fluent text where rabbits often
produces fluent text
that if you actually wanted to have a
good natural language generation system
you also have to have higher level
planning of what you're um going to talk
about and how you are going to express
it right so that in most situations in
natural language you think okay well i
want to explain to people
something about why it's important to do
math classes at college let me think how
to organize this maybe i should talk
about some of the different applications
where math turns up and how it's a
really good grounding you know whatever
you kind of plan out here's how i can
present some ideas right and that kind
of natural language generation um we're
not doing um any we haven't done any of
um
yeah i so
that's sort of saying more understanding
more generation which is most of nlp you
can say i mean obviously there are then
sort of particular tasks that we can
talk about that we either have or
haven't not explicitly addressed
okay
is there has there been any work in
putting language models into an
environment in which they can
communicate to achieve a task
and do you think this would help uh with
unsupervised learning
so again i guess there's been a lot of
work on immersion communication um
and also self-play
where you have like these uh different
uh
models which are initialized as language
models that attempt to communicate with
each other to solve some tasks and then
you know you have a reward at the end
um whether they were able to finish the
task or not and then based on that
reward you attempt to learn like a
communication
strategy
and this started out as like emergent
communication and self-play and then
there was like recent work i think it
was like i clear last year or the year
before that where they showed that
if you initialize these models with like
uh with like language model pre-training
you um
basically prevent this problem of like
language drift
where
the language that or the communication
protocol that your models end up
learning has nothing to do with like
actual language
um
and so yeah i mean from that sense there
has been some work um but it's like very
limited i think there's like some groups
that try to study this but not beyond
that
okay i mean the last two questions
are about gene
as well as one question about whether
gene smith
some correlations from social cues a
reward based system i don't know if
either of you have opinions about this
uh
but if you do
yeah i mean i don't have anything very
deep to say about this question so it's
on the importance of social cues as
opposed to pure reward based
systems well i mean in some sense a
social cue you could also regard as a
reward that people you know like to um
have other people put a smile on their
face when you say something um but you
know i do think generally um you know
not when people are saying what have we
not covered
another thing that we've barely covered
is the social side of language so you
know a huge
a huge interesting thing about
language is it has this very dynamic big
dynamic range so on the one hand you can
talk about very precise things in
language so you can sort of talk about
math formulas and steps in a proof and
things like that so that there's a lot
of precision and language but you know
on the other hand you can just sort of
emphatically mumble mumble whatever
words at all and you're not really sort
of communicating anything in the way of
a propositional content um what you're
really trying to communicate is you know
i'm oh i'm thinking about you right now
and oh i'm concerned um with how you're
feeling or whatever it is in the
circumstances right so that a huge part
of language use
is
in
forms of sort of social communication
between human beings and you know that's
another
big part of actually building um
successful
natural language systems right so if you
you know if you think negatively about
something like the virtual assistants
i've been falling back on a lot is you
know that they have virtually no
ability as
social language users right so we're now
training a generation of little kids
that what you should do is sort of bark
out commands
as if you were you know serving in the
german army in world war ii or something
and um
that there's none of the kind of social
part of how to you know use language um
to communicate um
satisfactorily with human beings and to
maintain a social system and that you
know that's a huge part of human
language use that kids have to learn and
learn to use successfully right you know
a lot of being successful in the world
is
you know
you know when you want someone to do
something for you you know that there
are good ways to
ask them for it you know some of its
choice of how to present the arguments
but you know some of it is by building
social rapport and asking nicely and
reasonably and making it seem like
you're a sweet person that other people
should do something for and you know
human beings are very good at that and
being good at that is a really important
skill for being able to navigate the
world well
you